[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I'm going to get started
pretty quickly because I know we're
running light a little bit late this
morning so today I'm going to talk about
how superset and druid power real-time
analytics at Airbnb but before I get
started on that I'm just going to
introduce myself briefly so my name is
bush my I hope that sometimes the
microphone goes goes out when when Sid
was fishing to when he would like turn
his head to the AESA I'll try to be a
little bit more robotic and turn sway
all right so so yeah my name is Maxim
Bushman I go by max to make it easy on
everyone
I work at at Airbnb I started this other
projects with which you might be
familiar with which is called Apache
airflow fun fact about it the sick Oh
like reach up the project and then we
spoke together and you kind of push me
to to go and join the Apache Software
Foundation to the airflow drawing the
ASF and then Sid has been super like a
drunk
great you guys let me know if I need to
use a proper microphone let's see
all right there has to be at least one
technical difficulty here that's just
the rule of text hopefully if this was
the technical difficulty my demo is
going to go well so yeah back to to
airflow so more recently I started
another project that's called super set
and which I'm going to be talking about
today and I'm going to try to sit you
know super set in context of like how we
use it at Airbnb and how we use it in
the specific case of real time data what
druid an interesting fact is that super
set is also joining the Apache Software
Foundation so soon it's going to be
called Apache super set I used to work
at Facebook we used to work at Yahoo and
at Ubisoft
I'm at a point where I don't really say
how long I've been working with data
because it's going to you know has just
like been too long now and definitely
been working with data since before it
was it was cool I just squeezed him this
new fly this morning because people were
talking about bid engineering and I
realized that it was data ang comp today
and recently I wrote this I wrote this
blog post called the rise of the data
engineer that's on medium and it got it
got super popular so who in the room has
read that post okay that's not bad news
and it leaves the room for four more
people to go and check it out but I was
trying to to really define in this blog
post like what is data engineering all
about and how does it relate to to say
previous related jobs like like business
intelligence engineer or data warehouse
architect and where it fits in you know
with data analyst data scientist in the
modern world so if you're interested you
can check that out and I put some
analytics not to brag about their
readings but it's going to cool that
medium has this data pipeline in this
data product where as an author of a
post you can see you know how many how
many reads you got and I think it's it's
relevant in this context is you can kind
of imagine all of the the pipeline and
all everything that takes place behind
the scene for this to happen alright so
this is the quick
Genda for this talk so first I'm going
to talk briefly about druid and say you
know a few words about what it's about
and what kind of database it is what are
the guarantees and properties that it
has that I'm going to quickly introduce
you know superset from a high level
perspective then we're going to do a
somewhat deep dive into the erbium views
data infrastructure would it focus on
real time and then this this
presentation is going to be largely a
superset demo so I want to really for
everyone in this room to get a good feel
for what superset does and does not do
and you know one of the takeaways that I
want people to walk away from this talk
with is you know is is super said
something I want to use in my in my
environment and hopefully by you know
listening to this talk you'll get a
sense for that and then we'll we're
going to take a little bit of a look of
what's under the hood of superset and
how it works and why we built it and on
how we built it and hopefully we're
going to have time for questions if not
so every for every speaker today there's
an office hour in a room that just as we
come out on the right at the end of the
hallway there so you can come and ask
questions and I'll be I'll be you know
happy to answer questions about my talk
or about airflow if you're interested in
an app - cool so I'm going to start with
drill just to set the foundation because
it's a really important part of our
infrastructure at Airbnb of our
real-time infrastructure at Airbnb so
grid is a blazing fast real-time
distributed column store I think it has
you know more buzzwords but this is as
many as I wanted to put in here but it's
it has an open source community that is
very thriving it's been battle tested at
larger large companies I believe some of
the people from Metamarkets are going to
be speaking in this conference and I'm
sure they're going to mention Druid so
Metamarkets was the mother company for
for druid I'm sorry I'm a little
congested this morning as well as at
Yahoo so Yahoo as a very large install
they're very bullish on dread and they
also use super set
at at Yahoo and there's like you know
hundreds of companies presumably that
are running droid so it is so red does
support real-time so you can load data
in a batch form to then we're going to
talk a little bit about how we use some
of these features later there's a column
store it is heavily indexed it is our
Zonta lis scalable and the way a droid
cluster works there's a lot of
specialized nodes that take on different
tasks that means that if you want to
really optimize and control that
infrastructure and ramp up certain
classes of nodes on your droid cluster
you can do so it assumes an OLAP type
workload contrarily to other no sequel
databases say like HBase or Cassandra
what in some cases these databases
assume that you know ahead of time the
kind of queries you're going to run and
it assumes that you're going to leverage
that primary index that they have and
you're going to structure your data a
certain way with Druid it really
supports arbitrary queries and it will
perform well whatever you filter on
group by that sort of thing so so you
can really load your data into it and
then ask all sorts of questions and
drill will perform well that's deep
support for sketches so sketches is this
thing that represents usually a
probabilistic count distinct said that
scale really often when you do web
analytics or different kinds of
analytics you need to do Kalen distinct
user ID count distinct you know you know
user pairs and it's pretty useful to do
that and it's usually pretty compute
intensive and it's a problem for a hard
problem for these types of databases and
drew it as a really good support for
sketches it's just really good and it's
a feature that we leverage quite a bit
so super set so that's just a quick
intro like what is super set before we
get into the demo so super set is a
modern enterprise ready business
intelligence web
I hate the term enterprise-ready
I also don't like the term business
intelligence those are kind of
antiquated and very corporate but it
still describes what superset is pretty
well enterprise really means you know it
is secure and you can create roles and
give access to different people to
different databases or schemas or tables
business intelligence because it is a
data consumption application and really
the idea behind superset is to explore
your data create interactive dashboards
and share discovery so it's really kind
of taking on in the open source space
we're taking a kind of head-on with
vendors like mode periscope looker and
even tableau all right so now I'm going
to get into Airbnb s data infrastructure
that is this slide is really the high
level data infrastructure and it's not
specific for real-time I will have
another slide after this where we can
explode the real-time portion of it and
I'm going to type talked quite a bit
about real-time works so at Airbnb we
use air flow of course at the very top
so this is how we schedule pretty much
all of our batch jobs and this is also
how we spin up in some cases some some
real-time services as well so we can
abuse air flow into running a
long-running services because somehow we
can and we do and then the flow you know
the main data sources that we have at
Airbnb are my sequel scrapes that we
scoop and and load into or gold high
cluster as well as event logs that you
know we stream into Kafka and also
somehow land into HDFS and our main high
cluster we do have two Hadoop clusters
because we for high availability reason
the gold cluster is the one that has all
of our raw data and all of our high SLA
super important pipelines so the
pipeline's that the data engineering
team will create to create the core
components or core schemas in the
warehouse and Silver's is a replication
that we can use for failover or for
disaster recovery and it's also the
sandbox and playground of our data
scientist data analyst and information
workers that want to run queries and
derive data and do all that crazy stuff
that data scientists do with data so we
do you know HDFS we use HDFS we
increasingly use s3 as a as a
distributed file system - because it's
cheaper and it's low maintenance and we
use SPARC quite a bit so they like a lot
of our ETL and and you know data
processing scheme is done using hive n
hql we increasingly use quite a bit of
spark to do all sorts of batch
processing now the bottom layer is more
towards consumption and then you know of
course superset I kind of made it look
bigger because this is what we're
talking about today but you can see that
superset sources data mostly from druid
so you see the pipeline here where you
have the event logs going to Casca
somehow make it into druid and then from
super set we can analyze this data in
real time we also take data from hive or
from a Hadoop in some context so the the
very hot data or the data that is
usually our core metrics and core
dimensions and large datasets that are
too slow to consume and presto because
they're big and important those we load
load into druid - as batch and we
consume some that data through super set
and so of course we superset works well
with presto and then we have these two
other consumption data consumption
visualization tools so air file which
we're deprecating it's an open source
project that is a sequel IDE on presto
that we're replacing in favor a super
set because super set is a super set of
air pal we support all the features that
air pal does so this network so we're
kind of going end of life with with air
pal and tableau somehow we use
decreasingly but we still have a lot of
good use cases for tableau internally
and you know I could get if we have time
or maybe in questions or in the office
hours I can talk a little bit more as to
when we use super set versus tableau a
little bit more about the event logs
here before I move on to the the real
time portion which is going to circle
them here so for event logging at Airbnb
I wish would use Avro that Sid talked
about earlier but we use the risk to
enforce schemas so for everything that
is long at Airbnb there is a thrift file
which defines the schema of what we log
and that allows us to enforce that that
the messages we load our that we log our
consistent and predictable and that
allows for better integration down the
line cool so now this is like looking
more into real time or streaming at
Airbnb and I'm going to start today
we're mostly interested in the flow that
goes from event logging to cascade a
spark streaming to druid and I'm going
to have another slide on this and this
is what we're focusing on today but I
want to talk about the other use cases
or the other ways that we do that we do
real time at Airbnb the first one I want
to talk about is how we stream the my
sequel bin log my sequel bin log is the
event log from our production my sequel
databases we push that into Casca with
something called spinal tap and somehow
in a spark streaming and then into HBase
so we do replay the my sequel bin log
into HBase which sounds kind of crazy
that allows us to have an age base it's
not a current snapshot of what's going
on in production that is very low
latency and there's this cool thing with
presto presto is a distributed query
engine that works very well with the
hive meta store and hive tables and
structures but Fred still knows how to
talk to other databases so there is a
presto connector for HBase that means we
can write a presto query that will query
essentially the equivalent of
or my sequel productions a user table
into HBase and that's useful because we
can join that table with a high table or
with other other things that impress the
nose out of query but the main advantage
of that of that streaming the binlong
into HBase is that we can take instance
snapshots of our my sequel tables into
HDFS and and the reason why that matters
is that the way you would do that so if
you want to scoop your mind sequel
database into Hadoop the way you might
natively do that is that you would take
a backup of your my sequel database at a
point in time say midnight take that
database restore it into some temporary
my sequel database and then now you have
like a static snapshot backup that's
been restored then you would scoop the
data out and then load it in at Airbnb
that we had we had some mileage out of
this technique but at some point in time
our data SLA s withstood load core data
which is going to the core portion of
our warehouse by 9:00 a.m. in the
morning and and it was just becoming
impossible to do that just because the
whole snapshot process and restore my
sequel was taking so much time right
because like just to take that backup
restore that backup scooped it out load
it in that became that it took you know
10 hours or something like that so we
had no more time to do our actual
compute and you know ETL so now that we
have this we can take you know H it's
really easy to take a snapshot from
HBase into HDFS and we can do that
instantly so at midnight o 1 we've got
we got our snapshot and we're ready to
run our ETL so it was quite a section
here on on some of the streams some of
the real-time stuff that we do you can
see that we also use this thing called
data dog who here is familiar with data
dog so data dog is a vendor and they
provide real-time analytics for your
servers you can log your own event
though we don't tend to do a lot of that
so for logging your own events we tend
to go the dredge route but data dog as a
an agent that runs
all of our machine that gets information
about the CPU load and all sorts of like
very operational metrics and we do you
know stream the data to that company
because data dog is a vendor and then
we're able to analyze it and do ops type
alert on it so that's another component
of real-time at Airbnb that is somewhat
complementary to the rest of the stuff
that we have and then and then we have
the drill use case with super set you
can imagine super set right behind druid
here and I'm going to kind of zoom in
into that as to how we load data into
druid here I wanted to to give you this
pointer to this other talk that
colleagues of mine that I've been saying
setting up a lot of this infrastructure
at Airbnb so Jingwei and leanne i've
given a talk at the spark summit
sometime last year or fairly recently
anyways and the videos on youtube so if
you want to learn more about the data
infrastructure the real time data
infrastructure at Airbnb I would
recommend you go and check out this talk
if you're interested now I want to talk
about how the little abstraction we have
to load data into droid so it's really
not that easy to load data into Giroud
and it's a common pattern at Airbnb we
need to get data in there and we need to
people to specify how they want to get
that data in there and you know if we
were to just say like write your own
spark streaming job and figure out what
the port and the host name is for the
druid server that wins scale very well
so we have this simple abstraction
called air OLAP and I'm going to try to
describe briefly how it works before we
get into the super set demo so two use
cases we load data into druid from casco
in real time and for the hot data in
hives that we want to make really fast
and really interactive
that is the second use case here you can
see hopefully you can read from as far
as you are but you can imagine that the
way it works is we ask people to to set
up a config file so the format here is
called ho con which is a superset of
JSON but it's a very simple config file
that describes
what are the dimensions and metrics that
you want to load into druid and what is
what is the casket topic and the thrift
schema you want to reference and define
you know what are the data types and now
this should be loaded you can imagine
that you could set up say a sampling
parameter say I want a sample based on
user ID 1% and things like that so this
is how you configure all data is going
to flow into druid so it's fairly easy
for any engineer data scientist an
engineer to go and drop a new whole con
file in this folder and that's all you
need to do for this to get picked up by
the spark streaming job so the spark
streaming job will reread that this
folder discover it and based on what it
finds it will start loading data into
drill on the right side is the very
similar config file to load a batch
process into droid so here the main
parameter is a sequel statement or hql
statement so this is assuming that we're
going to run a hive query and that the
output of this hive this high query is
going to get loaded into droid
so this is just a batch ingestion
portion so you can imagine that it would
also have the first section here on the
left and you define a number of shards
what is your time stamp column because I
drew it as a primary index on a on the
the time a date type column so it
assumes it's time series data and then
you define your sources and as you
define this their air flow job will
discover this config file and somehow
create a new mini dagger new tasks in
your workflow and start loading data
into Druid automatically alright so now
we're entering the super set portion of
this presentation so super set I want to
talk a little bit about the original
vision and and how it started and why
would a company like Airbnb build a
business intelligence web application
instead of just buying one so so the
original vision part of it was so we
wanted to do real time we wanted to
bring in Druid there was no tools out
there that
work with druid at the time I believe
now there is there are a few options now
to query and visualize data out of druid
but if you wanted to query druid before
you would have to write your own Jason
and your own little application so for
hackathon one day where other people had
been working on testing out test-driving
druid and doing a POC hundred internally
I decided to build a set of tools to be
able to visualize the data that was
inside druid and then you know I've been
playing with all sorts of d3 examples
which are kind of represented here on
the right side and it's always it's
always a pain to take your own data you
know take a d3 example and then you know
munde your data into the right json
format and load it in and then you got a
static HTML file on your you know on
your desktop on your local computer with
a data visualization you don't know how
to share it so i was like oh there's got
to be a way for someone to build a tool
where you can easily query any database
out there including druid do a
microscopic amount of work and get to
any visualization and that was the scope
of the project originally was what we
call the explore view which i'll demo in
just a little bit and eventually it grew
into in popularity at Airbnb on top of
druid and on top of I made it work with
presto and eventually it started a lot
of users started using it instead of
tableau just because it was easier in
low-friction and very easy to put
something together one thing I'd like to
say is that a trend that I see you know
India working bi for for a long time is
that the lifecycle of a dashboard or
data set seems to shrink over time so
that means that when you build a
dashboard today it might be the new hot
thing in your company for for a few
weeks and people are going to consume
and go to this dashboard every day until
there's been the new hot thing which
maybe people are talking about a new new
analytics problems and then a new
dashboard gets built and people people
focus shift very well very fast so used
to be that you'd build like the company
dashboard and it would be in production
for five years now it's more like you
run you build your own little dash
but for your team you use it it makes
them decision at some point you might
just move forward and start looking at a
different dashboard that represents the
the flavor of the week if you will so I
think it's important for tools to for
tools like super set and tablet to make
it really low friction to build
dashboards because dashboards have short
life cycles right so this brings us to
the live demo portion so we're going to
going to hope that everything goes well
so this is so this demo for context runs
off of my laptop with a my sequel
database running on my laptop so the
performance is fine is just not running
off of Druid I wish I could just VPN
into Airbnb and show you all the cool
dashboards that we do have at Airbnb and
and show you no app crashes of their
Airbnb app in real time and things like
that but I can't really do that I would
have to have everyone sign an SLA some
sort of NDA and I would rather not have
to do this I'm hoping lips this is my
screen sorry I need to move this over
here this was my desktop and I think
that means I'm going to have to turn to
my left while I do this demo maybe I
will yeah I'd rather not figure that out
right now okay cool so so this demo
today I'm going to show you the kind of
the core components a super set and
hopefully you'll get a sense for how
super set works and what it can do and
what it cannot do in this case we're
connected to this local database we're
not connected to druid but you can
assume the exact st. you would connect
to rid the exact same way as well I'm
demoing here
today and one interesting thing is that
you know you can install super set today
on your laptop and it's very easy you
can pip install super set follow a few
instructions on our documentation and
quickly you're going to get to this
screen with the exact same examples and
datasets that that you can start playing
with and quickly you can also connect to
your own databases whether that database
is local on your laptop or on one of
your servers provided you have attendant
you know
connection string and then you can start
you know making reports on your own data
so I'm going to start with just showing
a few dashboards because that is kind of
the top-down approach would be the show
dashboards and we're going to look at
individual charts and then into
something called sequel lab so this is a
dashboard you can see that we support
your classic type of data visualization
with some that are a little bit less
common here this is the context you know
where you would like move things around
and set your things and save your
dashboard and you know you could do we
have this thing where you can change the
CSS so this is where you would design
and consume your your dashboard so this
is the dashboard view and I'll show you
a few other dashboards I guess we have
only three to look at so this one here
is like health data by country over the
past would like 50 60 years this is the
world population and I really this is a
percentage of rural population per
country you can see a little bit more
you know there's different data
visualization that we can use box plot
and tree maps and bubble charts and
spectrum Sackhoff son sunburst diagram
and just good old tables and things we
have a lot we support a little bit of a
basic interactivity on the dashboard
meaning that you know you can you can
apply some filters if you want and these
will be reflected in the different
components
I believe this shows more or less the
dashboard view and I'm going to do this
thing so one thing that's great about
superset is any dashboards it's really
easy to and very natural to go from the
dashboard view and to the what we call
the Explorer view and this explores you
is where really the project started
originally and the first iteration at
hackathon we had essentially just this
one-page app here and the context here
is in this view you have all sorts of
controls on the left that allows you to
define a chart that is shown on the
right side
this is also where you would save these
what we call slices and you can you know
override then save them as and add them
to existing dashboards or create
dashboards from here and create a
collection create a dashboard as a
collection of slices as in slice and
dice so what I wanted to show briefly
here on the left side is that you have
these controls you know which data
source you're pointing to which
visualization type you wanna like which
way you want to visualize things you
know some time filtering so the time
filtering is either hard dates or you
know you can do relative time so right
things like now or three years ago or 15
days ago you can also change your time
grain so that means say if you were in
Druid looking at app crashes on to
Airbnb app you could look at I want to
look over the past 24 hour per minute
per region and eventually you could
drill down into like I want to look into
the per machine is there a specific
machine that's going poorly or something
like that here this is where you pick
your metrics so say and your your main
group I so instead of grouping by
country name or country code I might
want to query by region and that's all I
need to do so everyone that does not
speak sequel knows how to consume a
dashboard go into this Explorer view
explore a little bit further assemble
their own dashboard easily and share
that with people so it's very low
friction very easy to use and then you
can see that you know we have things
that are more like do you want to you
know some more basic parameters like do
you want to expose the legend or not do
you want to use this rich tooltip just
kind of a line a vertical line or a more
simple tooltip so tons and tons and tons
of options including some things that
are a little bit more data munging so
things like doing so if you want to do
so here we're doing a period ratio so
we're looking at the growth rate over
the past ten years or you can be looking
at a moving average and things like that
so we have these functions that we added
over time in the product so that you
know I wanted to spend a little bit of
time on the
or review because that's kind of the
heart of the application and gives you a
good sense for how it works you can
imagine that if you do change the type
of visualization so if I go towards a
word cloud here and I would like to look
say a word cloud by country code and my
query button then the list of controls
that you have access to are very
different because each data
visualization does not have the same
input so instead of taking the tableau
approach you know we take this approach
of adding very custom controls for each
visualization so as five minutes less
I'm gonna have to accelerate I want to
show now so you have you know options
you can see sorry easily download the
CSV you can see the query that super set
is running behind the scene all that
good stuff and now we have this sequel
editor which is an important component
here where you know it's a classic
sequel IDE that is multi-tab and you can
browse your your database objects so say
here I could look at the dashboard
tables and see you know what's a foreign
key and what is you know what seals are
index and that's that kind of stuff and
run my own queries and one cool thing is
that you can go and actually visualize
your result set at the click of a button
here so it kind of ties together if you
do speak sequel you can connect to all
your internal databases and visualize
them and create the create dashboards
off of your own queries to cool so that
is that ends the portion of the demo
since I have a five minutes left there's
a lot more to it I have a slide about
security but you can imagine here that
when I said Enterprise ready at the
beginning of the presentation I meant it
in a way that you can define who has
access to which feature of the
application very well and also who has
access to which database schema and
tables when they use super set
cool so back to
presentation all right so this is the
fallback if the demo the live demo
doesn't work I can fall back on these
slides so now you're going to see me
accelerate quite a bit because I have a
few minutes left so the stack is a
Python back-end we use pandas sequel
alchemy flash gap builders we use flash
and then this thing called flask ad
builder is a layer on top that does
authentication permission management and
crud and then we use all sources like
state of the art modern JavaScript like
react and redux and pretty proud I would
not have been proud of the state of our
JavaScript code base maybe like a year
ago now we're at a very very good place
security briefly so we ship with
different roles if you install super set
and your your company you can define
your own authentication scheme your own
roles there's a lot of controls there
for you to use we have this idea that I
did not show in the application of a
thin semantic layer so that means
semantic layer is a little bit of extra
metadata around your physical tables
that you want to expose and superset and
it says this is where you're both to say
which field should be groupable this is
also where you define your calculated
columns and calculated user-defined
metrics and things like that so there's
this layer where you can control all of
that we do do a lot of caching so if you
set up a caching back-end the dashboards
are going to load very very quickly
because we behind each chart there is a
JSON blob and we we cache that JSON blob
so that if people are running the same
queries we load them off of Redis
memcache or filesystem what depending on
how you set it up and the UI is really
upfront about serving cache data it will
show you very clearly and it will allow
you to force refresh if you wish so
there's also a cool airflow operator if
you want to warm up your cache so say
you load a table that's used by a
certain number of dashboards you can say
go and warm up the cache for for all of
the dashboards that use this table so
that
you know sometimes your tableau
dashboard people familiar with tableau
it might take you know a minute to load
and it's going to it's a really bad
experience in this case all of our
dashboards you know provided the cache
is warm will load really fast so briefly
superset is an open source project and
it's really take enough as we speed so
as we speak so 13,000 stars and lots of
Forks and lots of washers and lots of
commitment contribution so we're doing
pretty well and we're hoping to like
that this is just the beginning - we're
joining the Apache Software Foundation
so that means it's going to be called
patchy superset and it's easy for a
bigger company or companies to get
involved so I really I really like
today's renovation is in part a call to
it please like try su percent use it
join a community if you're interested
interested to do so we're announcing a
partnership with hardened works or
they're putting some engineers full-time
on the project because they're
committing to droid and to superset so
you're going to you're going to hear
these names more and more over the next
few years and I believe this is almost
done
I know I'm running out of time and so
what's next we're growing community and
that's part of the reason why the
reasons why I'm here today to grow
community and we're joining the Apache
Software Foundation we've got work to do
on polishing the UI so we're a team of
four engineers at Airbnb with a p.m. and
a designer and we want to make super set
super slick so that essentially there's
no friction you can just point it to a
table and start getting your data and
visualizing it and make charts and
dashboard instantly we want to [ __ ] ship
our JavaScript components so that people
can use them in their apps there's this
use case of integrating slice and dice
capabilities to other data applications
at Airbnb and everywhere in the world so
we want to make it really easy for
people to create to embed super set
components that will interact with the
super set back-end so you can picture
these JavaScript components are really
easy to setup
and our that are highly interactive and
lives in your application and then DSL
versus semantic layer I won't get into
details around that so check out
arrábida is super set this is their
documentation there's an installation
guide there I wonder if anyone did
install supersets during this
presentation it's totally possible to
install it and in a few minutes and then
you know all the actions in github we at
Airbnb or at least like for my projects
airflow and super set we do olive work
we take pride in doing all of our work
and be open to so we don't work behind
the curtain and push some code over the
fence every once in a while we do all of
our work in the open so so please check
it out and that's it do we have time for
questions I think is true sharing the
room I think we have time for questions
awesome cool good thing I sped up all
right yes microphone our idea Judy a is
going to sink you maybe get a session
anybody a question over there you so
house assumer said comply to you implies
you I so the first thing about implies
do I I believe you do so originally
there was a project called
pivot out of imply or out of meta market
and I think it was open source
originally but then they lost their
rights to it and Yahoo forked it and so
I'm not sure what's happening with pivot
I think Yahoo owns it now and an imply
is selling a UI for druid and that
really was pretty new so as of you know
six months ago there's that there is not
they did not have an offering in that
space and I have not seen their tooling
the main thing with superset is that we
can connect to any sequel speaking
database as well as druid so the scope
of what we can do is is more you know
it's it's broader in some ways but yeah
so people I encourage people if you if
you
or you're thinking about dreads you
should check out implies solution for
visualization imply is the company
behind druid so people that used to be
at meta market left to create this
company call imply and they sell
services around it I'm excited for like
competing with these guys and we're also
partners with them I have lunch with
them pretty often so it's cool to see
druid takes up take off and to have like
open source offerings in that space Hey
so really awesome I guess my question is
how you know there's a lot of startups
out there well funded startups that are
doing similar products you know good
data mode Domo bars yeah and they're in
taste they're creating entire startups
based around what you've presented here
which is essentially an open source
product that you've created you know as
inside of Airbnb so maybe you can just
walk us through tell us a little bit of
how how this came to be because it seems
like it would take a lot more people
than having a benefit that's relative
yeah I'm really happy to answer this
question so so the main thing is none of
these solution could talk to druid at
the time and I believe that is still the
case for periscope mode Tablo and and a
lot of them did not play well with
presto as well so a lot of them are they
work well with Amazon redshift and maybe
my sequel and Postgres one thing so I do
have a slide here that I kind of held
for after the question slide that I knew
I might have to use so it told the whole
build versus by for us at Airbnb and
also for others so there's some of the
elements that are rational for us to
build this so one is what Airbnb is
going to be a big company and we already
kind of are and data is very strategic
and we don't want to depend on vendors I
remember I used to be at Facebook and we
cannot rely on any vendors of any of any
form for the scale at which we were
operating and sometimes we've tried to
push in things with tableau and they
just it's not on their priority list and
their their roadmap and their iteration
cycles are
long and even though we'd like to help
them on these things we cannot so
sometimes we like to own some of these
things Tablo did not really support any
form of presto Indrid which are
databases or choice and that is true of
other vendors here I say tablet tablet
that looks as that was our main our main
focus or that is our main alternative at
Airbnb tableau extracts don't play well
like at beyond like a few hundred
million rows it just breaks down and the
reality is Airbnb we need to we often
have tables that are multi billion
records that we need to interact with
and doesn't seem to be any solution and
tableau side for us and you know druid
can really say that on easily and we
don't like you know buy-in and the fact
that we're locked in and then there's
going to play games in some cases we're
committed to open source or whole stack
is open source and we want to you know
for the visualization layer to be as
well we we do all sort of like deep
integration and the stuff I was talking
about it's just like embedding super set
components into other data analytical
application at Airbnb is really
important to us and we can't really do
that with vendor tools so that means we
need to build all sorts of stuff anyways
and then personally like I I'm an
engineer I like to build stuff and I got
hired at Airbnb and I would much rather
build stuff then and be excited about it
than supporting vendor packages that we
don't really control and we can really
collaborate with so those are some of
the reason and fully that addresses your
question Thank You max alright thank you
very much